We are now hearing from the
person responsible
for speaking on behalf of the Atlanta
based grand jury
that investigated
former President Trump's
attempts to overturn the 2020 election.
That is the jury for woman
confirming that multiple indictments
have been recommended
saying it's not a short list.
The grand jury met about seven months
and heard from witnesses
testimony from 75 witnesses,
including some of Trump's
closest advisers.
Fulton County District Attorney
Fanny Willis is now reviewing
those recommendations and weighing
charging decisions.
Emily Core is up to name of the jury for
woman says
she wants to see
some level of accountability.
I will be sad if nothing happens
like that.
That's about my only request
there is is for something to happen.
I don't necessarily know what it is.
I'm not the legal expert
I'm not the judge.
I'm not the lawyers. But
I.
I will be frustrated if nothing happens.
Oh, wow. Okay.
So joining us now,
CNN political analyst and New York Times
senior political correspondent
Maggie Haberman.
So it's interesting to hear
a foreperson say
that said she'd be surprised
if nothing happened.
Let me just ask you,
I think it's important to hear from her
to set this up with what happened.
Poppy mentioned
77 months hearing testimony
from 75 witnesses
who made their recommendations
regarding the indictment.
Then finally, Willis
who's a Fulton County district attorney,
she made the recommendations.
The foreperson in the grand
jury said this, where she is
sort of seemingly saying
that there might be an indictment
for the forum.
I want to hear what you have to think.
Oh, here it is.
We definitely
heard a
lot about former President Trump
and we definitely
discussed him a lot in the room.
And I will say that
when this list comes out, you wouldn't.
There are no major plot twists
waiting for you.
So we'll hear. Won't he?
I mean, maybe.
Perhaps.
I mean, look,
she certainly seems
like she's teasing that,
you know, stay tuned
that something is coming related to him.
But she doesn't
go further than that, I assume,
because she got some instructions
on what she could actually say.
Unusual to hear.
I've never heard.
I've covered courts on and off
for the last 20 years. Or more than that.
I've never heard
of a grand jury foreperson
speaking this way.
This is a fact finding grand jury.
This is not a charging grand jury.
But even still,
I've never seen anything like it.
If I'm the prosecutor,
I'm not sure that I want
this media tour taking place
because I'm confident that Donald Trump's
lawyers are going to use this
just based on what I was hearing
last night from people
to try to argue
that this is prejudicial
in terms of what she is saying.
It was interesting
to Don's
point about what
the what
Trump came out and said on social media
and through social thinking.
The special grand jury
saying total exoneration.
And I can't imagine
being finding Willis right now.
Like you've
got your foreperson out there
as you're trying to make this decision.
It didn't she say like,
did he actually read the documents
when he said that, right? Yeah.
And this was not a total
exoneration, frankly,
any more than the Mueller report
was a total exoneration.
Which he said about that, too.
But that's, I think, a separate issue
from what
the grand jury for a woman is saying.
I mean, she's given this
extensive media tour.
I saw some quotes
that I think she gave
to The Atlanta Journal Constitution
where
she was asked about that quote, where
Trump said this is an exoneration.
And she started laughing and said,
oh, that's fantastic. I love that.
I don't see how that's helpful.
If you're a prosecutor,
because what he will is still has to
it's not automatic
that charges get filed.
Now, that that seems like
that's the likeliest thing to do.
Finally, Willis
is a very aggressive prosecutor
but this is just,
you know,
at least in my experience
covering courts, not helpful
to a district attorney
when they are trying
to put their case together.
Let me read you the first line
from your reporting.
You say former
President Donald Trump,
who throughout his business
career had a reputation
for not paying lawyers, spent
nearly
$10 million from his political action
committee on his own legal fees
last year. Federal elections filing show.
So him running for president.
Does that help to pay for his legal fees?
If he wasn't running, he'd
have to pay it himself.
And this whole idea about it.
Well, if I'm being investigated,
if he's being investigated,
then perhaps
there won't be an indictment.
So there's a gray area as to
what happens with his.
These are this is from his PAC.
And this was the PAC
that had
all of this money
raised into it initially
at the end of 20, 22, I think in
excuse me,
20, 20
early 2021
on claims
of investigating widespread fraud.
They did spend
some of the money for that.
They obviously did not confirm
there was widespread fraud,
but they started
this turned into a
into a wide broad use PAC.
He was able to use that money
to pay his personal legal fees.
Now that he's a candidate.
There are some experts
on campaign finance who actually think
he can't use it anymore.
Not being able to have other people
pay for him
has always been
a disincentive to Donald Trump.
So I don't know what that looks like
going forward as he's facing
at the moment.
Two trials in April
related to aging, Carol.
The woman who has accused him of rape,
he is facing an intensified
Georgia investigation,
intensified New York
investigation and intensified
Justice Department investigations.
This is, again,
a guy who is facing enormous legal issues
and the potential
of paying for this himself,
which he never likes.
Let's switch gears here,
because former President Trump
is going to Ohio
today, East
Palestine to be specific,
the site of the toxic train wreck
in a county
where he won more than 70% of the vote
in 2020.
And as Nikki Haley is criticizing Biden
for not going to the transportation
secretary which hasn't been yet
Trump capitalizing.
Yeah I mean
if this was not a Trump
plus 20 district as you just said
I don't think
you would be seeing him there.
If this was anything that was
you know much closer electorally
he has been looking for opportunities
to put himself in the news cycle
we were just talking
about fundraising and money
that he has raised.
His campaign has not raised
a ton of money.
And that is part of why
you are not seeing him do big rallies
because those are very expensive.
So he's looking for ways
to put himself in
and look as if he's you know,
a contrasting president
with with President Biden.
It can be very dicey
when people show up,
when they have no actual role in a
in a disaster.
And so
he's not known
for his empathy to begin with.
So we will see how this visit goes.